I pour a lot of myself into making sure
that what I'm doing is amazing practice
makes perfect
come on Dallas give us the love what's
that believe nation I'm going to Dallas
she's coming for a little bit of it too
we're gonna take you guys on the chip
with us
[Music]
so my friend Jeremy West has an event of
video marketing world in Dallas
basically working with brains and
entrepreneurs have mostly brains on how
they can be doing better online and I am
the closing keynote speaker so I'm going
down for three days and then Nina's
gonna join me hello Nina for three more
days it's a long weekend in Canada so
we're gonna explore Dallas we were
supposed to see Dallas New Year's but
our flight got delayed and then
cancelled we sat on the tarmac that was
not fun but this time it is like 40
degrees I don't know what that is in
Fahrenheit but it's hot it's real hot so
don't have to worry about flights
getting canceled than snowstorms that
hold account Nina this is set unlike
Smurf mode okay when you're a big person
in a little-person world you know anyway
we're off to the airport let's go to
Dallas
[Music]
occupying wifey we're gonna miss you
everybody's gonna everybody's gonna miss
her we're gonna miss her so much
have a great day I'll see you in a
couple days I bet it's a love fight
it's a love fight alright let's go let's
go let's go
[Music]
so it's just past 8 o'clock my flight
leaves at 11:30 got here early so that
Nina could get to work so I got I got to
check in and do some work
answer some DMS catch up on some emails
maybe pump out some fire IG content for
you guys what are you doing downtime
downtime extra time at work at work
that was the fastest entry through
customs of all time
this trip is off to a fantastic start
next stop breakfast this is an
interesting dilemma I usually don't eat
breakfast
until noon I don't have solid toaster
noon just usually coffee and some water
but my flight I got to be on board by
11:00 and I'm not gonna get in until to
something and I don't think they're
gonna give me a lunch on the plane I
don't know so I don't want to pass out
so I'm making an executive decision to
eat breakfast and give myself a break
for not doing my exact goal today
sometimes you got to forgive yourself
make me be judgment call
I'm gonna enjoy my breakfast okay that
line that was a little too ridiculous
the lineup I didn't get at the customs I
got a Tim Horton's so there's other
places to eat I'm teaching them a lesson
with my patronage you get frustrated
with the business you don't have to give
them money you'll spend your money
somewhere else so I ain't I Tim Hortons
right now and I'm gonna find some other
food to eat
[Music]
all right made it this is actually my
first time not just Dallas with the
Texas travel a bunch across the u.s. but
never never to Texas so pretty smooth
flight usually in the flight I like
catching up on my overseas movies I love
the I love the action movies the Asian
movies in Japanese movies but all the
Asian ones were dramas every
international movie even the Indian ones
are fun was all drama
so nothing for me to watch unfortunately
but there was this new movie I watched
called like gamer up first gamer up like
that it'd be pretty good so now I'm
gonna find my I'm gonna get it uber and
get to my hotel and start practicing it
for my presentation the first thing I
notice it is hot
we are not in Canada
hi of 40 degrees again we don't know
what that is here
Fahrenheit but it is hot it is hot I'm
in the shade I got my shades on and I'm
very hot I like you like it
every time Nina comes with ARMA trip
with me and is it being crazy rain is
hoping that this is the first time no
crazy rain come on Dallas
give us the love so I'm here at the
Gaylord Texan
look at this you'll bigger you go home
in Texas right that's how it works place
is huge I love it
that's hilarious so the guys at the desk
super nice man there's some big-time
youtubers coming in here big-time
big-time youtubers the last guy you met
at 50,000 subscribers are you a youtuber
too like yeah man I'm a youtuber how
many you got 1.5 million yeah oh my god
you're so big time all right man thank
you for the love maybe I should ask that
I got me another hmm
this is a gorgeous hotel it's a gorgeous
hotel and resort it's huge
look at how huge this thing is all this
stuff
gotta go explore but first gotta find my
room 413 oh nice look at this let's get
some lights going on hey that's a nice
bathroom we got some funky Texas art
look at that double sink not that I need
it I got two beds no Nina so won't need
that one all right see if we get some
CNN but I'm not really on vacation got a
desk and I got a view of some crazy
patio with a blue Smurfette you see the
blue Smurfette right there's like a blue
Smurfette so what about what I do I want
to sleep I did not get a lot of sleep
last night so I need to get some rest
tonight my presentation is in two days
there's an event happening tonight at 6
o'clock I think it's like 2:30 right now
2:30 I'm going to go live on Instagram
because I missed it because I was on the
airplane so I'll say hi to some of you
guys give me your question
in then I'm gonna practice so I didn't
sleep well last night because I was
thinking about my presentation I always
I always I don't know I don't know if
I'd say stress myself out but I always I
pour a lot of myself into making sure
that what I'm doing is amazing so I put
a lot of pressure myself like I'm here
you know Nina's gonna join me for the
second part but I'm here for three days
right like this is what these today
Tuesday no Wednesday Wednesday Thursday
and then it comes Friday normally I
would fly home so maybe three days three
days is a lot of like I can get a lot of
work done in three days I can I can do a
lot of stuff in three days and I just
put a lot of pressure I'm here for one
speech I'm spending three days of my
time for one speech and I'll do more and
I'll meet people and I'll try to bring
more value but it's like three days of
not being home not working not mentoring
not doing the work that I'd normally do
so I put a lot of pressure on making
sure that I give a kick-ass speech and
so I was up last night just going over
my points thinking about other examples
bringing more passion to it and I don't
know if I'm going to sleep the next two
nights until I get my speech and then
Nina comes and we enjoy the rest of our
trip so I'm gonna go Instagram live
practice my speech sleep are then to the
party that's Instagram
what what what are you doing how are you
doing I don't know I'm I'm a little out
of sorts today just got into my Dallas
hotel
I just did my Instagram live it was a
strange one I was not on top of my game
but we had some funny moments I think I
think kind of like loopy Evan might be a
good addition every now and then to the
to the vlog or Instagram live sessions
we've had some fun times
so I after that session I don't know is
I think it's been like half an hour so
I feel mild fever coming on so I'm gonna
practice my speech for about an hour I'm
gonna go maybe lie down have a nap I'm
definitely gonna go find some food to
get something salty inside me and then
it is three o'clock the YouTube meetup
greet up event registration dining thing
is at 6:00 so gotta make this time count
three hours what are you going to do in
the next three hours you're gonna make
you count - lets go okay
presentation practice done for now it's
how I intend to work through
presentations especially new ones where
I happen this is a new topic for me
where I'm helping brains most of the
stuff that I do is helping entrepreneurs
when I help brands it's more kind of
one-on-one not really at the front doing
presentations so especially the new
topic what I'd like to do is is I do a
rough draft I do a rough draft I create
a deck and then I do it I work it I
practice it and do it again I'm gonna do
it again and then with time with
multiple days with more practice
sessions it just it starts to flow it's
it's a stick I never look at this view
that's it I never I never do about
safety exactly like you do it in my room
but every time I practice it a new idea
a new way of saying it a better more
clear understanding comes out and it
just helps so I'm comfort I think it's
gonna be really good even if honestly
even if I did it as I did it just now my
room you'd be amazing but I know it's
still gonna get better because I'm gonna
practice again tonight and I'm gonna
practice again tomorrow multiple times
hanging there practice it again the
Friday until it's time to go on stage
practice makes perfect
right now though I'm gonna go see if I
can get something salty fix this
headache
the Gargamel wizard Academy Hayden would
love this
[Music]
Jeremy Vance
what's this video marketing thing right
this guy's the organizer mr. Jeremy vest
okay check out what I got I got two tiny
bags of Doritos the salt I got a little
bit of sugar with some gummy worms and
then the huge chef's salad this thing
cost me $23 I think so not getting the
bargain here but definitely worth it to
go to this headache so normally at this
time I like this time normally I would
be down meeting people my strategy is
typically wear a shirt that's branded
sit in the middle of the biggest room in
the lobby probably and then be busy and
not just look busy but actually be busy
something with high energy high
intensity so it'd be like making videos
doing Instagram dm's Twitter DM z--
writing backs just like giving energy
into the phone it attracts a little bit
of attention I try not to be obnoxious
but I get a little bit of attention
because there's an energy happening and
then people come and introduce
themselves to me and say hi and we start
conversations because I'm not the one
usually who goes and says hi because I'm
introverted so I create a scenario where
people come to me I know a lot of the
people here already which is great and
I'm the keynote speaker and when I speak
I like knowing the people in the
audience it's a huge honor to be the
last person like they hear me and then I
have to close the show what I don't like
about that is the conversations always
then they want to have a talk afterwards
and I wish like I'd much rather open it
up so then I have three days of
conversations people because I really
want to make sure that they're getting
value and I can help them as much as
possible so I really want to be down
there right now I want to meet people I
want to say hi I want to I want to
understand their problems I want to
start building some energy and I can see
their faces when I do
the actual presentation but I feel
myself noting the best spots health-wise
at the moment with my head so I'm going
to fight myself my urge to go down and
help to relax to the next hour 45 eat my
meal maybe watch some CNN do some work
and then 6 o'clock go meet everybody
hopefully not have to late at night
because tomorrow tomorrow yeah gotta be
healthy bring value and have lots of fun
feeling a little better management talk
to Nina I have that belt that she got
home from work at a decent time so we
could have a quick chat before I'm out
for the night still feeling some
wooziness but excited
registration first function go meet some
YouTube entrepreneurs big value
[Music]
this is the big room this is where it's
all gonna happen Jamie's looking fancy
okay
jingling time oh did not film lunch but
had fun met some fans met a lot of fans
oh I went a little nuts didn't I I went
a little nuts it is 10:17 yeah that was
opposed to end at 9:00 anyway had some
great conversations went to dinner with
Tim Schmoyer and another friend and just
got back I had a burger it was good my
head is pounding pounding but look at
what the look at what the Gaylord Texan
sent us look they left us into my door
mister I can't move backwards sorry mr.
Carmichael Thank You mr. Carmichael jeez
thank you so much for staying with us we
look at up your YouTube Kent you're a
star it was an honor meeting you shall
Mora Kramer there you go
where's my upgrade it's all good this is
a beautiful this is a beautiful room
this is a beautiful location tomorrow is
the start of the conference and Tim I
think is up first so I am I'm going to I
need to sleep I need to sleep head is
pounding I need to sleep and have a
great day tomorrow so thank you guys for
joining me today I believe in you I hope
you two need to believe in yourself and
your one word and I'll see you tomorrow
if you guys are curious and you want to
see the video of us not making it to
Dallas because we got stuck in the
airport check out the link next to me
continue to believe I'll see you there
kings of the plane
figure it out see that's like a ball
back